Daniel do you have an opinion then on
this long-standing debate about the dead
hand because whether a a philanthropist
should engage in his or her philanthropy
while they're alive so that they have
some amount of input and control or
whether they should in fact set up
something that survives them after their
death in perpetuity or some limited time
frame bill gates of course actually has
a limited time frame to which the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation will
continue to exist so as to prevent sort
of a previous generations thoughts on
Philanthropy effecting a future
generation I think it touches on in my
opinion touches on to things and I'd
love to learn from the closet but
basically it's what's the most effective
way to address a challenge / perpetuity
versus spend down immediately to me
seems arbitrary if you're not taking the
problems into account if there are
issues of injustice what will it take to
solve the problem it raises a broader
issue of is the foundation the exclusive
vehicle to do that what's the broader
coalition but to me the questions of
perpetuity spend down or not I find less
compelling than what are the most
effective ways to address challenging
issues